it's been way too long - Rick and Morty
is Morty in the universe are back
I'm not rated to climb something this
year look you're the guy that wanted
this epic adventure I'm the guy with
only one hover chair and things are
pretty much the same and that's the end
of the Morty gets a dragon experiment
are you gonna play it first off I always
slay it Queen secondly yes
let that selves sit for 10 minutes or
you'll die don't let it sit for 12 or
I'll have to hunt down what you become
ripoff doctor strange you know what
you're right I could get used to this
magic stuff
people who are really dying don't keep
bringing it up is it true I don't know
I'm just usually around people that die
faster that's which you know what this
one counts as one of your adventures
Rick and Morty
five all new episodes starts Sunday
November 10th at 11:30 half the season
you deserve all the season we could
handle 40 what did I tell you only on
Adult Swim welcome back everyone it's
Charlie we have a brand new Rick and
Morty's season for official trailer to
breakdown and we're getting it a week
earlier than I thought it was going to
drop there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs they're dropping bodies like flies
in this to r.i.p gearhead r.i.p Morty's
10 free adventures I will be doing
episode videos and Easter eggs all
season long so be sure to subscribe if
you're brand new to my channel there's
also a merch giveaway that I'm doing
every week that I'll explain at the end
of the video important stuff first
though they're officially premiering the
season November 10th and those are gonna
air five episodes go on break for the
holidays then come back and air the
second half of the season there's ten
episodes total in season four so it's
just the first half of the season that
we're getting right now they did the
exact same thing during season 1 so I'll
talk about that second block of episodes
at the end of the video but all this
footage in the trailer is from across
those five new episodes not just the
first two or three episodes the first
clip is also from that preview that they
released earlier this year of Rick
looking all blissful walking through the
tall grass they seemingly fly to this
tropical lush planet is hard to tell
based on way they cut the trailer but
this next clip of them entering the
ancient temple looking like an Indiana
Jones parody mixed with some guardians
of the galaxy seems like it's all
happening on the same planet they have
all these traps in the ceiling the floor
with the robot statues the statues even
kind of looked like the droidekas from
Star Wars Episode one Phantom Menace
Rick and Morty put on those clear
looking bulletproof armor jackets and it
looks like Rick's going full-on world
Endor episode levels of not caring about
the danger like he could care less about
what's happening here with all these
traps even Morty doesn't seem that
concern but maybe at this point they've
had so many adventures together that
he's started to trust Rick's technology
a little more even if he still doesn't
completely trust Rick himself whatever
his secret reasons might be it sounds
like
Morty wanted to use the last of his 10
free adventure cart punches like we're
gonna have to call this one an adventure
boom as he clears out his adventure card
guess we gonna to start a new one of
these so apparently that's why Rick
brings him to this planet the scene of
Rick eating fast food on his hover chair
while Morty is free climbing the cliff
face without any ropes is just a parody
of Star Trek 5 the final frontier if you
haven't seen that movie it's not one of
the better Star Trek's general rule of
thumb for the original series movies is
that the even number ones are the good
ones but it's literally that exact same
scene you have Kirk climbing the rock
face without any special technology like
Morty then Spock using the hover boots
to talk to him just making fun of the
whole thing like Rick is doing asking
the question what's the point of
climbing this mountain he even falls off
the cliff face just like Captain Kirk
did Spock had to use the hover boost to
rescue him from being dashed on the
rocks below so apparently Rick is
probably gonna have to do the same thing
here but you also notice that Rick is
eating Arby's because they flashed the
rapper pretty prominently I'm assuming
that this is just official product
placement to earn the show some extra
money they've actually done stuff like
this before they even did a full-blown
Carl's jr. commercial why you gotta keep
selling us out Rick they just earns them
a whole bunch of extra money from those
advertisers that pay to have their
products put in the episodes they shot
at them running with the cat person
named chachi is on a different planet
but the color of the terrain makes it
seem a little bit like the mega seeds
planet that's probably just a
coincidence though because you don't see
any of those trees in the background
they just seem like they're there to
steal something from this other group of
aliens that are chasing them down r.i.p
chachi you will be remembered until
another quirky character is introduced
to the group then on a different planet
good to see you Rick still cares about
Morty sheltering from the laser blast
but there are different colors so it
seems like a completely different group
that they're running from with his giant
gia that they're running to hide behind
then apparently Rick gives Morty a
dragon to take care of in one of the
episodes whether he makes one or they
just bring one from another planet this
is probably just the show taking shots
at Game of Thrones Season eight because
then Rick refers to summer as
quote-unquote Queen as in Queen Daenerys
Targaryen mother of dragons pretty safe
bet that they're gonna have some Game of
Thrones themed Rick Dragonslayer merch
also glad to see that the meeseeks are
back finally people been asking for a
couple seasons
when they're gonna come back in a big
way but they're tearing shit up on the
regular just riding in the streets the
funny thing about this too is that they
look super happy while they're doing it
unlike the me six episode from season
one when they were losing their minds
because they couldn't die so this might
be some accident that someone gets into
where they asked the meeseeks to do
something it in pursuit of that task
they wind up just completely going crazy
because then you see Morty wearing a
very inspired looking uniform on
Rick's spaceship fighting a meeseeks
with gearhead in the back crapping his
pants and Morty straight-up winds up
shooting him in the head
r.i.p gearhead for some reason summer
and Beth are going at it dueling with
golf clubs and assorted bagage items
from the airport tarmac here while this
baggage handler in the background could
just give a crap just going about his
job like it's no big deal
there's a giant hole in the glass
walkway up here too so they are really
tearing into each other for some reason
but then Morty looks like he's on some
adventure by himself because they have
that big Acura reference literally the
cop in the cop car calls it out over the
comm we got an Akira type situation
going on behind the mall here everybody
knows the basic premise of Akira the
government experimenting on kids trying
to create super soldiers until they
start to evolve beyond their control the
main antagonist Tetsuo starts going
crazy growing at an exponential rate
akira the titular character has to
reform his body to stop him then they
get sucked into a black hole and it's
implied the Tetsuo becomes so powerful
that he creates an entire new universe
if you don't remember earlier this year
they even released a Rick and Morty
style trailer for Akira
this screaming head in the microwave
inside the garage is giving me
flashbacks to the ABCs of Beth from
season 3 where Beth and Jerry had to
clone Tommy and then stick him in the
microwave as part of the process
here's another akira joke when Rick
gives Morty that special burn ointment
and says you're gonna die if you don't
leave this on long enough but if you
leave it on too long I'll have to hunt
what you become just like they had to
hunt down Tetsuo
during the akira movie which morty then
completely fails at because he begins to
turn into this winged demon looking
monstrosity charging away with rick
going after him with his gun morty and
jerry going on an adventure what could
possibly go wrong this actually looks
like it's part of that glooty episode
that they released a comic-con with
taiko YTD playing the app developer
alien that was sassing them there was a
spaceship in orbit that they kept
referring to during that clip so this
might be that the aliens feet sticking
out of their armor also looks exactly
like Lu Dee's feet this is Rick and
Morty looking like they're crashing some
kind of alien meeting or convention this
might be a joke about Hall H at Comic
Con or just some general comic-con joke
because of the Marvel of Doctor Strange
joke and in this exterior shot of the
alien city you see all these heist
convention banners with Rick stealing
these alien spaceship while they're busy
trying to heist all this material off
the building a heist within a heist but
Rick does show off some new personal
safety tech that causes them to phase
the security guard the Doctor Strange
joke is just them literally ripping off
dr. strange the writers making fun of
themselves for ripping off the plot of
that movie with the sentient cloak of
levitation choking an enemy out Rick
Morty and some are escaping during a
different adventure that looks like some
sort of sci-fi fantasy mashup Dungeons &
Dragons style some are wearing an outfit
looks like it's inspired by Lord of the
Rings or The Hobbit this seems odd but
Rick's weapon is turning aliens into
footballs and other random objects like
he shoots this alien then punched the
football that he turns into he's known
for having weird guns that turn people
into other things like the gun that
turned people into snakes but that was
pure science and he keeps referring to
magic in this episode I could get used
to this magic hard to tell if this is
random because the guns then shoots the
next alien and turns it into a potted
plan also news rick has morphine built
into a spinal cord I'm sure that's gonna
come in handy
welcome back mr. poopy butthole who's
apparently living as a professor with
hostile students who for some reason are
trying to attack him but he's apparently
now a ninja who's fighting them off with
his cane looks like he's actually pretty
badass - Morty complaining about dying
Rick shrugging it off that's pretty much
their relationship
his wounds here actually look a lot like
the wounds during Morty's mind blowers
when he was trying to get rid of that
giant demon tapeworm inside of him and
for some reason there's a dead astronaut
snake on their dashboard inside an
astronaut suit with a cracked helmet and
what looks like an American flag snakes
in space who knows what's going on here
and then they remind you five episodes
November 10th that means that they don't
take a break for Thanksgiving then
Episode five will air December 8th
they'll go on break for the holidays
then hopefully they'll come back in
January to air the second block of five
episodes like I said they did the exact
same thing during season one and when
they came back in January it was the
second week in January so you have to
wait that long through the holiday is to
get brand-new episodes but it's hard to
tell if they're gonna do this from now
on where they air smaller blocks of
episodes multiple times a year or if
this is just because of the holidays
we're doing a merch giveaway every week
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and just leave your favorite
Rick and Morty moment from the trailer
on the video I'll name a giveaway winner
when I post my next video I had one
ready to go I wasn't expecting this
trailer to drop so that knew Rick and
Morty video should post in the next week
while you wait for everything click here
for all my Rick and Morty's season 4
promos and trailer videos and click here
for my joker movie review thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight